David wait no is there no way we can get
rid of him
not without cause Michael I have cause
it is because I hate him so uh have you
felt the vibe yet we work hard we play
hard sometimes we play hard when we
should be working hard right
um I guess the uh
the atmosphere that I've created here is
that I'm a friend first and a boss
second probably uh Entertainer third
just a second
right
oh hey do uh do you like the Jamie
Kennedy experiment yeah it punked and
all that kind of stuff okay
um you are going to be my accomplice
just go along with it okay all right
just follow my lead don't pimp me all
right come in
so uh corporate just said that I don't
want to oh thank you Pam can you come in
here for a second
let's have a seat I was gonna call you
in anyway
um you know Ryan
as you know
there's going to be downsizing and uh
you have made my life
so much easier
in that I am going to have to let you go
first
what why
why well theft and stealing stealing
um what am I supposed to have stolen
Post-it notes
Post-it notes what are those worth like
50 cents 50 cents yeah you steal a
thousand Post-it notes at 50 cents a
piece and you know you've made a profit
margin you know go run us out of
business Pam are you serious
yeah I am
um I can't believe this I mean I've
never even stolen as much as a paper
clip and now you're firing me
but the best thing about it is that uh
We're not gonna have to give you any
severance pay
because that is
gross misconduct and uh did I just clean
out your desk I'm sorry
you have an ex-punk
surprise it's a joke we were joking
around see okay he was in on it he was
my accomplice and there was just kind of
a morale booster thing and we were
showing the new guy around kind of kind
of giving him the feel of the place so
you God you were we totally got you
you're a jerk
I don't know about that
okay everybody
what's up
earlier today Stan Lee sassed me and
Toby gave me some suggestions on how to
discipline him they did not work
obviously because they were stupid so I
am now going to fake fire him
what does that mean it's like a mock
execution that's
yes it is a good idea it's the only
possible solution I have left well you
can actually fire him no okay
I've had enough of you why are you
telling us this because I want you to
behave as if I'm actually firing him
Oscar okay Michael if you hadn't told us
this then we would have thought that you
were actually firing I'm not firing him
I'm not I will need you to act like I am
firing him
just what I'm going to do is I'm going
to pretend that I'm firing him and I
need you to act like I am firing him do
you get that do you get it I'm teaching
him a lesson he needs to learn humility
all right that's all okay here he comes
let's just
Play Act
Sally may I talk to you for a second
Stanley Hudson
you are fired
are you serious
I am serious we are all serious
you are fired like a heart attack you're
firing me over three words have you lost
your mind do you think I'm gonna let you
do this to me I've watched you screw up
this office for 10 years and I'm filing
a lawsuit and I'm going to tell them
about every stupid thing you've ever
done up in this office all right all
right okay you know what
now you know how I feel
this was a fake firing
lesson learned good work everybody very
nice
so I'm not fired that's it
and uh
do you have anything to say to me oh yes
I do
you are out of your damn little
pea-sized mind what is wrong with you do
you have any sense at all okay do you
have any idea how to run an office every
day you do something stupider than you
did the day before and I think there's
no possible way he can top that but what
do you do you find a way damn it to top
it you are professional idiot hey stop
it
damn
you come in here please
have a seat okay
well there's no easy way of saying this
so I think I will just
drag it out
since the dawn of time just tell me
I gave Ryan the sales job
there just weren't enough clients for
the two of you
so I had to okay sorry I'm sorry I get
it yeah
why are you giggling
is this a joke
Michael is this
did I get the job
yes I did yeah for real you're not
kidding
I did you're the best person for the job
you're gonna be great okay thank you
okay thank you thank you sorry it was in
your face oh man oh that was classic oh
I really thought I didn't get it oh
really yeah because you said I did that
was really good what about Ryan I don't
know I offered him his temp job back
we'll see he was not happy at all when I
offered him this job and then I told him
that he didn't get the job though yeah
maybe you shouldn't fake fire people
anymore I don't appreciate you telling
me what to do so clean out your desk you
are through here
thanks Michael oh
receptionist name Aaron could you send
her in
Aaron Michael wants to see you
you are great and very ambitious
and I feel like you want more than this
little office has to offer and I
understand that you'd want to just
spread your wings
fly The Coop what are you telling me
we're gonna have to you you want
something better no I don't I want to
stay right here
no you want to leave no I won't stay
here why are you making this so hard
um I think there's a misunderstanding I
think you're right can I go no of course
you can't go we haven't even started
this horrible process of
okay Creed I need to let somebody go
today
they told me I need to let somebody go
and as much as I think you're a great
guy and I like you you're you're goodbye
let's fight it let's call Jan and fight
this thing together like the old days
not old days what are you talking about
did you start the paperwork yet it's
right here on the desk yeah you don't
have to do this Michael I
undo it Uncle I really didn't mean help
me
I'm sorry I want you to role play
firing me I want you to fire me and I
will take it
oh you want me to be you yes okay I want
you to be me and I will be Creed or you
find Creed no no no that's just first
thing can't then head we should switch
seats in order to yes that's a good idea
all right
excuse me
all right but I have to let you go
purely budgetary and it's not personal
corporate is really breathing down my
neck and they're saying this has to be
done by the end of the month are you
being you or is this great are you I'm
this is Creed okay I'm improvising to
just try to keep up
and I'm very angry and I want I'm gonna
kill you kill you for firing I really
have to take this Creed so it was really
pleasure
just just